[Musique]
suite et fin de notre série sur les
véloroutes de la région et aujourd'hui
on vous emmène sur l'itinéraire le plus
connu de France la Loire à Vélo chaque
année elle attire plus d'un million de
cyclotouristes et là nous sommes à
Chaumont-sur-Loire sur l'une des
portions de l'itinéraire accompagné de
Pascal maro joueur de vélo mais aussi
amoureux de la région Pascal moi je vais
vous suivre vous allez me faire
découvrir un peu le coin allez c'est
parti on y va Corentin
[Musique]
on est sur le port de Chaumont-sur-Loire
c'est ça on est sur le port de
Chaumont-sur-Loire et vous voyez que la
Loire à vélo qui est juste devant nous
en fait le longe ce qui est bien c'est
que c'est votre environnement quotidien
de travail et de vie on a de la chance
quand même en effet alors pas juste ici
et en effet moi je viens assez souvent
le plus souvent possible à vélo de chez
moi et donc je prends l'itinéraire de la
Loire à vélo c'est mon bureau du matin
ça c'est pas mal c'est quoi les
sensations qu'on a quand on traverse la
Loire tous les tous les matins tous nos
sens sont mis en éveil dès le matin les
odeurs
Louis évidemment avec les oiseaux avec
les animaux la Loire et son
environnement change tout le temps je me
lâche jamais je me lâche jamais tout
simplement de ces paysages de bord de
Loire
bon avec toutes ces pérégrinations moi
je commence à avoir un peu faim est-ce
que vous connaissez un petit lieu où on
peut aller se reposer et restaurer alors
je vous propose qu'on aille en effet
nous accompagner jusqu'au restaurant
food Loire ce sont des amis à moi un ami
d'enfants voilà Didier Dupuis et sa
famille bah écoutez on va y aller alors
mais le temps d'y arriver on va regarder
ce reportage tourné à Candé sur Beuvron
on est allé voir la famille théveno qui
tient une exploitation viticole
familiale alors on se retrouve tout à
l'heure
en bordure de la Loire à vélo c'est en
le domaine de la famille Thévenot 25
hectares de vigne cultivés sur un
terrain classé haute valeur
environnementale c'est des 2022 c'est
des rouges qui ont une belle couleur
dans le chai le Cheverny rouge cuvait
2022 a tendance et barrique de chaîne
avant d'être mise en bouteille
ça nous permet d'avoir une diversité de
goût donc on produit un autre rouge plus
léger qui est celui-ci un rouge un petit
peu plus corsé
de belles viandes grillées voilà on peut
du corps en 2022 c'est une excellente
année et donc on peut le servir sur
toute une diversité de plats avec sauf
le plat trop relevé quoi
quelques mètres plus loin un autre
chevalier repose dans ses cuves
métalliques en tout 55 000 bouteilles
sont vendues chaque année
[Applaudissements]
cela fait 4 générations que la famille
de Daniel théno est dans l'agriculture
et presque 50 quel produit du vin nous
on a appris un virage viticole avec la
création de l'appellation Cheverny
d'abord en VDQS Cheverny en 1973 ce qui
ordonné un peu une notoriété au vignoble
et puis reconnaissance aussi de qualité
puis surtout un encouragement et ça
c'est concrétisé en 1993 donc avec
l'obtention de l'AOP Cheverny
le vin du domaine a déjà été récompensé
par de multiples prix comme le concours
général agricole et l'avenir semble
assurer puisque le fils Vincent a repris
la terre il y a quelques années
[Musique]
bonjour à tous les deux bonjour Didier
et Valentin Dupuis père et fils c'est ça
donc vous êtes en charge du restaurant
foudloir et ça fait combien de temps
alors que qu'elle existe qu'il existe ce
restaurant alors du coup on a monté
l'affaire et à un an le restaurant on a
ouvert le 20 mai l'année dernière on
défend principalement notre culture de
patrimoine à travers des produits locaux
et en mettant en avant le plaisir de
manger sur les bords de Loire
on n'avait pas du tout envisagé de faire
aussi pousser dans la restauration mais
en fait les clients sont demandeurs et
que le passage il est vraiment devant la
Loire à vélo et les gens s'arrêtent ils
ont ils ont envie de profiter et en fait
de faire une pause une demi-heure et des
fois il reste une heure quoi parce
qu'ils sont bien
on a beaucoup de gens qui nous disent
quand on vient là on est on se sent
apaisés et c'est vrai que le fait d'être
dans un esprit un peu jardin c'est pas
mal ça plaît on a essayé de mettre en
place un cadre qui ne correspond on
travaille dans une ambiance qui nous
correspond et voilà le but c'est que les
gens se sentent bien et se sentent un
peu comme à la maison tout en admirant
une vue imprenable quoi sur la loi
merci à tous les deux pour votre accueil
merci à vous voilà donc c'est la fin de
cette série d'été c'est en bonne
compagnie qu'on la termine et nous on va
aller se restaurer et puis se reposer
avant de pourquoi pas partir pour de
prochaines aventures à bientôt
[Musique]